فشل البرلمان اللبناني الاماراتيه السابعه
على التوالي في انتخاب رئيس جديد
للجمهوريه خلفا للرئيس السابق ميشال عون
الذي انتهت ولايته نهايه اكتوبر الماضي
في دوره الاقتراع الاولى في جلسه اليوم
التي فقدت نصابها الدستوريه في دوره
الاقتراع الثانيه
الخميس المقبل موعدا لجلسه جديده لانتخاب
الرئيس
من امام البرلمان اللبناني في بيروت تنضم
الينا مراسلاتنا كثرين حنا كاترين للمره
السابعه اذا يفشل البرلمان في اختيار
الرئيس الجديد ما الذي جرى وما هي كواليس
هذه الجلسه
نعم مريم الذي جرى هو نفسه الذي كان يجري
في الجلسات الست السابقه السيناريو نفسه
المشهد نفسه يتكرروا للمره السابعه وهذا
ما كان متوقعا بطبيعه الحال بحيث ان
التوافق مازال متعثرا وغير متوفر من اجل
تامين اي فريق سياسي الاكثريا المرجحه
لفوز اي مرشح في هذه الجلسه مرشح القوات
والكتائب والحسبه الاشتراكي من شان
المعوضناه 42 صوتا وصوت 50 نائبا بورقه
بيضاء بالاضافه الى نواب اخرين صوتوا
باسماء اخرى متفرقه ولكن الفرق بين
الاصوات التي
عدد الاوراق البيت في هذه الجلسه الفرق
بين هذه الجلسه والجلسات السابقه ليس فرقا
كبيرا او مهما يمكن البناء عليه بحيث ان
اي من الفريقين ما زال بعيدا جدا عن الرقم
المطلوب من اجل الفوز في انتخابات رئاسه
الجمهوريه بعض النواب الذين التقيناهم ما
عند خروجهم من هذه الجلسه والمواقف التي
اطلقوها عبرت عما وصفوه بامتعاظ واحباط من
هذا المشهد المتكرر وهذه الحلقه المفرغه
بحسب وصفها لانتخابات رئاسه الجمهوريه
وتحدثوا عن ضروره الخروج من هذه الحلقه
المفرغه وهذه الدوامه من اجل التوصل الى
توافق في اقرب وقت حتى المواصفات التي
تحدث عنها الاصدقاء السياسيون
الرئيس المطلوب بانتخابه
هناك من يتحدث عن رئيس توافقي اخرون
يتحدثون عن رئيس رئيس تحدي او رئيس
الانقادي حزب الله مثلا يتحدث عن رئيس
تطمئن له المقاومه اخرون كالتيار الوطني
الحر برئاسه جبران بصير يتحدثون عن وجوب
انتخاب رئيسنا يكون ذا همم تمثيل شعبي وزن
كل هذه المواصفات وتباينات تؤشر الى ان
الحله والانفراج على مستوى انتخابات رئاسه
الجمهوريه في لبنان مازال حتى هذه اللحظه
بعيدا وغير متوفر
كاترين حنا من امام مجلس النواب في بيروت
شكرا جزيلا لك